[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i saw where shaq barrett shaq had his
all-time basketball team at each
position
steve nash allen iverson kevin durant
dirk nowitzki
the joker and his sixth man jamal
crawford
jack barrett joins us now i think i
could come up with a better team than
that shaq if that's your
starting five i i think i i i think i
could uh
do some damage against you that's my uh
my favorite at each position mine is the
center yoke is just real good and he's
been
bawling a lot lately but i probably
could come up with a better
five overall starting five for sure okay
all right uh well congratulations last
time we had john after the super bowl
you said you're going to try to make it
work in tempo
if there was another team involved in
this like how close was it that you were
going to go to another team and
what team was that did it come down to
uh pretty much was tampa and tampa and
town he was giving type of every
opportunity to uh
to keep me here and to make it work and
it uh it worked out perfectly so
i really didn't want to have to leave
and go anywhere else to be honest that's
why i said it from the jump that
tampa was my plan a and i'm happy that i
had to get to plan b
but did you get another offer that was
better than tampa's offer
i did not get another offer that was
better than time okay yeah
okay so that that's easy did you hear
from tom brady yet
uh well i uh check my instagram
last night but he asked him a message
earlier yesterday morning
and uh just just saying that he hoped we
could work some out and get back
together i'm like yeah me too
i want to be back here we got something
special going and i am back here now and
i'm happy to keep building on what we
got going right now
isn't it nice you don't have to move
like you don't like your wife's probably
saying oh we gotta pack up or we're
gonna pack up or where are we gonna move
to
you don't have to move maybe a bigger
house
yeah we most definitely had to move
because we was renting the one we in now
since we're going to be here for a few
years we want to buy and uh we actually
was looking we got a couple houses that
we're looking at today that we're going
to choose from
good for you is that your big purchase
are you going to buy anything special
so i had my home home in colorado
already but i do have to buy a home down
here
and i have i have my car that i want all
right i'm gonna just get me
probably another tesla a tesla roadster
eventually
and then i'm gonna give my wife a nice
little car as a gift as well
nice what was the car you thought about
what was the car you wanted growing up
uh i always wanted for somewhere i
wanted the h2 hummer and i wanted the
raindrop
you don't want those here you don't want
those now no
no i got over the hummer pretty quickly
but yeah they ain't come up with no new
ones that make me want to get one i
wasn't a h3 homa type guy
and then the range rover i don't know i
just
just just skipped that all together now
that i have tesla teslas i love to test
take us back to the super bowl in the
game plan that you guys had
to put pressure on mahomes so we need uh
just coming into the game
that it could be up to the guys up front
we knew that we could apply a lot of
pressure we could affect the game a lot
and uh coach bowles just was letting us
rush he wasn't
having to do anything else but rush you
know
not typically but sometimes we drive
back in courage sometimes we uh
just have a different assignment but
that game he was just letting us pin our
ears back and go
yeah because i look back on that and the
offensive line was not healthy with
kansas city and they had replaced some
guys there
and it just felt like hey we think
if they want to beat us running the
football or little short passes go ahead
we're just going we're going after
mahomes but when did you
know we're winning this game
i believe i know i believe that the
whole entire week coming and leading up
and toy
i just knew that we wanted it we weren't
going to let this opportunity slip by
that if he was going to lose we're going
to play our best game pass when they was
going to beat our best game
like they deserve to win so we we like i
really have no doubt
leading up to it at all you weren't in
bad shape like brady was at the
celebration
the uh the boat celebration were you
shank
no no no i had a couple of drinks but i
was uh i wasn't
sipping no avocado tequila that's
probably what it was
but you're not used to seeing brady like
that
no no i'm not used to him but i'mma get
used to getting used to seeing him like
that because
we got a lot of a lot more to accomplish
here
help me here are you a defensive end a
linebacker or
edge i think uh
edge i just say adds it's the best way
to describe my position
pass rush drop backing coverage
occasionally
the edge of the defense so yeah i think
ads would be
appropriate um and i'm we're going to
test your basketball and honor during
the celebrity bracket challenge with us
do you know anything
is your bracket done by the way you know
anything about college basketball
my bracket will be done in a few minutes
but uh
i haven't kept up with it as much since
my mavericks not gonna have like a real
good pick in the draft that's when i
keep up with it the most is when my
marriage is not doing good
it might be a lot of routine uh and
you're from
maryland but but you were but then you
moved to nebraska
yeah i finished two years of high school
and one year college in nebraska then
transferred to colorado state who was
your team in uh baltimore growing up
uh my basketball team yeah the mavericks
i was a maverick fan well i used to like
a.i so i used to like the sixers
but then a little late i uh gravitated
towards that was
wait just because of nash and dirk
yeah really just because
have you met those guys i met dirk
before i haven't met an ass yet
he's a big dude dirk yeah dirky cool
she was real cool when i met him man i
actually got down to go to i was able to
go down to the maverick facility shoot
around there a couple times
for one of my homeboys so it was cool
it's a good people they got good people
in that organization for sure did you
get to shoot with dirk
no i met him at uh the nuggets game when
i was in colorado that's when i met dirk
at the nuggets again
yeah uh what do you got off season plans
here
we do we having a baby coming up next
month so
we can't do too much but we've been
taking advantage of florida we
went down to a little resort down in
orlando
kissimmee and now we're going down to
legoland this weekend
but i think that's gonna be the last
thing you could do since the baby gonna
be on the way
boy or girl girl you got a name
yeah yeah we have a name uh aurelia oreo
okay yeah how about middle name edge
middle name h or brady how about brady
it could work if i had a boy but a girl
i don't think my wife going for that if
you had a boy
could you say to your wife how about
brady
barrett uh uh not not realistically i
can't say that i could joke around
saying it but
realistically no she wouldn't be going
for that i wouldn't
be going forward you you like brady you
don't
like him that much yeah yeah brady eat a
goat for sure he'll go
[Laughter]
i wonder do you friends and family ask
if you can get
an autograph of brady for them or you
know can you get something signed
you know because a lot of people always
do that they'll like use you to see if
they could get to
somebody do you have that with your
family
uh not like my family family but like
outside
like friends they'd be asking like oh
now i gotta take care of my
signature from brady first and after
that wait you don't have anything
from brady no i have a jersey i got the
jersey from uh the atlanta game when we
came back and beat the liner the first
time
oh cool but is that in your is that in
your uh man cave there
that's your office isn't it uh no that's
my son's game remember you used to be my
gamer but i switched mine so this is my
sun game where i'm now but all my
jerseys
is hanging has been hung up in colorado
i have a nice collection down there
already
and i just got my tom uh i just mailed
it to my guy
uh brian that framed the art in colorado
he's a framing i'm all up for me
nice give me the jersey i'd be surprised
at seeing in your house in denver
maybe a a lucca jersey or a dirt not
dirt can see my favorite player
luca jersey maybe antoine randwell
or wait you have a luca jersey
yeah i have a luca jersey nice i have a
sign league of jersey sign dirk jersey
antoine randall he was a
a coach with his lashes i got his jersey
and then i got a lot of like
a lot of my homeboys from colorado state
that i played in denver with but that
wouldn't be surprising
well congrats on the contract and uh
good luck with the baby there and uh
most importantly good luck in the
bracket challenge because you don't want
to get
you don't want to get embarrassed jack
okay yes sir
i'm gonna put my best foot forward all
right thank you bud
all right yeah i'll take it to you take
it easy thank you that's shaq baron he's
a
edge rusher for the buccaneers just
signed a four-year 72 million dollar
contract